In Germany, the copilot of the plane suspected of intentionally crashing the Germanwings A320,...
...required treatment for depression.
In Pakistan, a bomb planted on a motorcycle detonates near a passing bus in Karachi,...
...killing two and injuring 13 others.
In Bangladesh, at least ten were killed in a stampede...
...during a bathing ritual at a holy site in Narayanganj.
In Syria, the UN says the humanitarian crisis is becoming increasingly grim...
...with the government limiting delivery of aid to three of the 33 sites requested in 2015.
And finally from England, King Richard III was buried with pomp...
...after his remains were found under a parking lot more than 500 years...
...after he was killed on the battlefield.